and he's getting old you just can't make
it in sunshine the Beatles that they
kicked out the original drummer like
that right he was a drummer right well
[ __ ] Peter if you bring in Ringo he was
uh it was it was so sad
Pete best I was listening to this
Malcolm Gladwell book on tape it's
called outliers and they got into a part
about the Beatles The Beatles man when
this Pete Pete passed he was there in
the beginning man he did these crazy
gigs with them could you imagine like
you being a part of a band and then you
get kicked out of that band it turns
into the beat oh I mean that's never
happened before I mean no one's ever
before right so no one has ever been is
that him right there oh he doesn't look
like you fits in does he how about one
has ever been that guy I bet he went
home with a surimi when they first oh my
god there was nothing like that before
that that's the people say that that was
all staged Bieber's are faking to I'll
send you a link the Biebs has the same
effect on this a man girls lose nobody
mine nobody a certain dudes bring that
footage look at those chicks dude that's
quitting us they didn't have the
Internet they didn't know they're being
dorks that was natural every girl
naturally feels there's no Instagram
there's no Instagram there's nothing so
first time you see them in person we it
was set up as their possible what the
conspiracy now we have a we have an idea
of what women are based on how women
behave around us when they're worried
about the way we think about them the
same way we behave differently when it's
all us when there's no women around
there's just a ways that people behave
and if you leave all these women
together hold on a second if you leave
all these women together and it's 19
what what year was that said what's that
the 62 but in late sixties right when
she died dude they didn't
barely have books back then they're
happy to get out the kitchen there's a
Beatles Roxy I'm girl screaming of
course they had books I'm joking but
when I'm not joking around about is that
they no one had ever experienced
anything like that point if you get all
these girls together and they're seeing
these guys who they're seeing on
television then they're seen on The Ed
Sullivan Show and there's they're seeing
him everywhere and they sit there in the
newspapers in the magazines and they see
these guys and the sounds they make are
so good the way they sing and play music
together is so magical and it's so
unprecedented and it's a new kind of
sound and they're just special you know
these girls just can't help it like me
you know when you see a taping of a TV
show
yeah did you ever see the big applause
like yeah applause they make is that a
real applause applause that's lights
they're not a conspiracy they're not a
conspiracy but they are kind of cheesy
dude you look at Justin Bieber's concert
I mean listen I've worked he's hot as
[ __ ] he is hot but I work sick I work
security for like some of these bands
and I worked for the when Hilary Duff
was in her a day I'm talking [ __ ]
passing out from excitement at they grab
their big asses out of the crowd yeah
that's not fake that is real dude I'm
talking [ __ ] crying I have to
understand girls have a completely
different reaction not all girls but
some some dude to you bro you remember
the reactions there's a there's a lot of
Beatles footage of the audience but
there's girls just [ __ ] flipping out
screaming and crying like just going
nuts you remember those two shots a
hundred percent
look do do I think that girls would act
up to get on camera
to make it a bigger deal yes do I think
that's what they were all doing no look
at this mayhem dude I think they
couldn't believe that the Beatles were
actually there there had never been
anybody like the Beatles before [ __ ]
Thursday dude I think they were just
hypnotized there's something singing out
in there
about that music cuz look we can listen
to the Beals today and it's still great
I listened to the White Album just the
other day it was amazing how was it from
beginning to end it was sexy they
weren't like for drugs they're [ __ ]
here cuz don't have to basic did don't
not know it's the music it's the music
they're so good and this this movie or
this book rather the Malcolm Gladwell
was all about extraordinary performances
like what people have done that's been
completely extraordinary and one of them
was talking about how the Beatles got so
good because they played I think it was
Berlin was where they put our Hamburg
one of those books so they played
somewhere where they played all night
they played like multiple hours a night
and they played every day they played a
insane number run a lot in front of
audiences they just played constantly
and he talked about the importance of
that the by the time we got to see them
by the time they were on television they
had played together so many more times
than the average band were will do in
their entire career like the sheer
numbers they were always playing always
doing these live performances I forget
where it was with the cavern club where
was it he was at the cavern club is what
it was called I think nowhere is the
place that they performed early in their
career I want to say it's Hamburg this
is the first of a long series of
resident nights during a traditional
jazz evening they performed an interval
as the only rock group during an
all-night session including jazz maybe
it might be one of the many things
they've done I would not think this was
before they made it this was like as
they were like young guys coming up just
so many repetitions yeah and he talked
about out and they think about that Pete
best dude he's going [ __ ] I was in the
mix what did he end up doing anything he
start his own band how do you recover
from that my biggest cell here's the
thing there's never been a Beatles
before so we're looking at the Beatles
like we already know they're awesome
they're already a part of pop culture
history I miss them I'm younger yeah but
if we lived back
and man if it was like 1963 and the
Beatles burst in the scene you would be
like wow
is there anything close that now it were
too we have too much stimulus we see it
too much we Instagram we get inside
their lives it's hard there's